Welcome to our second drink of Goodbye Toby Part 1. This episode kicks off the end of season four of The Office. Wow. Yeah. We had a lot of fun folks from our office family sharing behind the scenes details with us for this two-parter. So thank you once again to Jen Salada, Paul Lieberstein, Kit Zabornak, and Creed Bratton. Angela, this is also the episode where we got into a debate about what the phrase hot to drop means. Yes, I know.
欢迎收听我们关于《再见，托比》第一部分的第二杯饮品。这一集开启了《办公室》第四季的终章。哇。没错。我们和办公室大家庭里的许多有趣的人一起分享了这两集背后的细节。所以再次感谢珍·萨拉塔、保罗·利伯斯坦、基特·扎博纳克和克里德·布拉顿。安吉拉，这一集我们也讨论了“hot to trot”这个短语的意思。是的，我知道。
People wrote in. Maria F. said, I first heard hot to trot on happy days. Richie was going to a dinner at a divorcee's house. His friends say, you know what they say about divorcees. They're hot to trot. Jenna is correct. Because I said hot to trot means you're hooking up. Yeah, and you said it means you're mad.
大家写信来了。玛丽亚·F说，我第一次听到“hot to trot”是在《欢乐时光》里。里奇要去一个离异女人的家里吃晚饭。他的朋友们说，你知道他们是怎么评价离异女人的吗？她们“hot to trot”（急不可耐）。珍娜是对的。因为我说“hot to trot”的意思是你想找人约会。是的，而你说它的意思是你在生气。
Yeah, you're coming in hot to trot. You're ticked off about something. Well, Raquel G says, Angela, I have also used hot to trot in the same way you did. And Linda G. wants us to know that it has two meanings and we are both correct. Thank you, Linda. I do remember a few people DMing me saying, I think you meant like hot under the collar, Angela. Yes, hot under the collar. I'm hot under the collar. It's definitely means you're getting mad. Well, I still say hot to trot when I'm mad, but I'm more careful where I say it. Well, here's a question I have for you. Now that you've learned this second meaning for it,
是的，你气势汹汹地走进来。你对某事感到恼火。好吧，拉奎尔·G说，安吉拉，我也一直像你那样使用“hot to trot”。琳达·G想让我们知道它有两个含义，我们俩都对。谢谢你，琳达。我确实记得有几个人私信我说，安吉拉，我想你指的是“hot under the collar”（怒火中烧）。是的，“hot under the collar”。我怒火中烧。它绝对是指你很生气。好吧，我还是会在生气时说“hot to trot”，但我说的时候会更小心。好吧，我有个问题要问你。既然你现在知道了它的第二个含义，
Have you ever said to Josh, sweetie, I am hot to trot? No. And he thinks you're mad, but really you mean it the other way? No, I've never said it. I've never said it. Because he probably had to learn in your relationship. If you said, I am hot to trot, it's not what you're not to think. No, it means you're mad about something.
你有没有对乔什说过，亲爱的，我“hot to trot”？没有。他以为你在生气，但其实你是那个意思？没有，我从来没说过。我从来没说过。因为他可能在你们的关系中不得不学到，如果你说“I am hot to trot”，那不是他想的那样。不，它的意思是你在为某事生气。
Hmm. Hmm. I like to keep it interesting. You never know. I'm going to interpret something. Okay, we also got a great background catch. Louisa C said, ladies, at exactly two minutes, I noticed something shiny on Steve's hand. I stopped and I saw that Steve had his wedding ring on.
嗯。嗯。我喜欢保持有趣。你永远不知道。我会去解读一些东西。好的，我们还收到了一个很棒的背景发现。路易莎·C说，女士们，在两分钟整的时候，我注意到史蒂夫的手上有闪闪发光的东西。我暂停了一下，看到史蒂夫戴着他的结婚戒指。
All right. Louisa, I went and I looked. You are absolutely right. It's in the cold open when Michael is dancing through the office. It's part of a montage. It's Toby's last day. Michael is very excited. And he's sort of doing this scissor move with his arms, like as he's dancing through the office.
好的。路易莎，我去看了。你是绝对正确的。那是在迈克尔在办公室里跳舞的冷开场中。这是蒙太奇的一部分。那是托比的最后一天。迈克尔非常兴奋。他在办公室里跳舞时，手臂做着这种剪刀动作。
And when he's sort of like slides his arm, across the screen, you see his wedding ring. He must have forgotten to take it off, but clearly someone caught it because then immediately right after he has a talking head to camera, and it's gone. Wow, that's a good catch. Do you remember that week that Steve jammed his finger playing hockey and he couldn't get his wedding ring off? So we had to cover it with a band-aid? Yes. Oh my gosh. I forgot about that. Yeah. Because he was like, you're not cutting this off my finger, obviously. So there's, I can't remember what episode it is, but I think it's in season three. We talked about it on the pot. We also got this observation from James L in Arizona who said,
当他把手臂滑过屏幕时，你能看到他的结婚戒指。他一定忘了把它摘下来，但显然有人发现了，因为紧接着他有一个对着镜头的采访，戒指就不见了。哇，真是个好发现。你还记得史蒂夫打曲棍球时手指受伤，摘不下结婚戒指的那一周吗？所以我们不得不贴个创可贴盖住它？是的。天哪。我忘了那件事了。是的。因为他当时说，你显然不能把这东西从我手指上切下来。所以，我不记得是哪一集了，但我认为是在第三季。我们在播客里谈过。我们还收到了亚利桑那州詹姆斯·L的观察，他说，
Hi, ladies, this is my second listen to the podcast. I have a long commute and decided to go all the way back to the beginning and listen through again. And I wanted to point out that Pam is wearing a pink sweater in this episode. It's not the same one that you discuss in a later episode as in Pam's sex sweater theory, but I want to throw this out there. Maybe Pam just wears pink when she's feeling extra happy. Loving the second drinks, James. I love that. She is wearing pink. Yeah. I mean, it's not her sex sweater. No, but she does get good news. She learns about the Pratt Institute, and then she's super flirty and gives Jim a little kiss. She's happy. True. Yeah. Well, I love that question. Well, when we first broke down this episode, I shared that there were some awesome Phyllis deleted scenes.
嗨，女士们，这是我第二次听这个播客。我通勤时间很长，决定从头开始再听一遍。我想指出，帕姆在这一集中穿着一件粉红色的毛衣。它不是你在后面一集中讨论的帕姆的“性感毛衣理论”里的那件，但我还是想提一下。也许帕姆只是在感觉特别开心时穿粉红色。喜欢这些第二杯饮品，詹姆斯。我喜欢这个。她确实穿着粉红色。是的。我是说，那不是她的性感毛衣。不，但她确实得到了好消息。她得知了普拉特学院的事，然后她超级调皮，给了吉姆一个吻。她很开心。真的。是的。好吧，我喜欢那个问题。当我们第一次拆解这一集时，我分享说有一些很棒的菲利斯删减片段。
One of my favorites that we discussed was put back in the superfan version. I really want us to hear it. Okay, to set the scene for you guys, Phyllis is super stressed about planning the party, and Jim walks in. This is so great. I'm so glad it's back in. You got to hear it. Well, who can do a party of this size? But you're in the business.
我们讨论过的我最喜欢的片段之一被放回了超级粉丝版本中。我真的很想让我们听听。好的，为了给你们设定场景，菲利斯对策划派对感到压力巨大，吉姆走了进来。这太棒了。我很高兴它被放回来了。你们一定要听听。好吧，谁能承办这么大规模的派对？但你是做这一行的。
You must surely know of some other businesses. Okay, well, I just want a damn dance floor. I'm sorry. So sorry. I shouldn't have sworn. I'm so sorry. Thanks for your time. What?
你肯定知道其他一些商家。好吧，我只是想要一个该死的舞池。对不起。很抱歉。我不该骂人的。真的很抱歉。谢谢你的时间。什么？
Sorry, I shouldn't have said what like that. It was really rude. Scared me. How's the party planning going? Jim, I am so f***. So it's going great, sounds like. I don't know. I'm not used to this dress.
抱歉，我不该那样说“什么”。真的很粗鲁。吓到我了。派对策划得怎么样了？吉姆，我真是搞砸了。所以听起来进展很顺利。我不知道。我不习惯这种压力。
That's so funny. I should say the top of the scene, she's pacing on the phone. She's with some type of like event, you know, party rental place. Yes. Oh my gosh. Oh. Well, that was all amazing.
太搞笑了。我应该说在场景开始时，她正在电话里踱步。她是在联系某种活动，你知道，派对租赁场所。是的。天哪。哦。好吧，那真是太棒了。
Everyone, now here is your second drink of Goodbye Toby, Part 1. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies.
各位，现在是你们的《再见，托比》第一部分的第二杯饮品。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你们制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会拆解《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hello, everyone. Howdy. Today, we are breaking down. Goodbye, Toby, Part 1. I can't believe it. We're at the end of season 4. I can't believe it, Jenna. I'm excited, though.
大家好。嘿。今天，我们要拆解《再见，托比》第一部分。我不敢相信。我们到了第四季的终点。我不敢相信，珍娜。不过我很兴奋。
This is such a good episode. Oh, I loved it. Beyond Loved It. It is Season 4, Episode 18, written by Jen Salata and Paul Lieberstein, and directed by Paul Feig. Hashtag beyond loved. Yeah.
这一集太棒了。哦，我爱死它了。超越了喜爱。这是第四季第18集，由珍·萨拉塔和保罗·利伯斯坦编剧，保罗·费格执导。标签：超越喜爱。是的。
Beyond Love. Well, I know you've got a great summary and some fast facts. I can't wait to hear them. Let's get started. Toby is moving to Costa Rica. Finally, his lifelong dream is coming true. Michael insists the party planning committee plan a huge going away party, and when Angela Box, he puts Phyllis in charge.
超越喜爱。好吧，我知道你有一个很棒的总结和一些速记事实。我迫不及待想听了。让我们开始吧。托比要搬到哥斯达黎加了。终于，他毕生的梦想成真了。迈克尔坚持要求派对策划委员会策划一个盛大的欢送派对，当安吉拉反对时，他让菲利斯负责。
Oh, can you believe it? I mean, she does a really good job. You know what? I don't need to hear it. Well, I'm going to talk about it more later. Well, okay. There is a new HR representative coming in. Holly Flacks.
哦，你敢相信吗？我是说，她做得非常好。你知道吗？我不需要听这个。好吧，我稍后会多谈谈。好吧，好的。有一个新的人力资源代表要来了。霍莉·弗拉克斯。
She will be taking over for Toby, and this is her first day at Dunder Mifflin. Michael assumes he will hate her, but he is quickly smitten. Very quickly. Very quickly. But that is Michael. I mean, Michael falls in love at hello. He does. Meanwhile, Pam gets some good news.
她将接替托比，这是她在邓德·米夫林的头一天。迈克尔以为他会讨厌她，但他很快就被迷住了。非常快。非常快。但那就是迈克尔。我是说，迈克尔一见钟情。他确实如此。与此同时，帕姆得到了一些好消息。
Should we get started? Fast fact number one, I thought you were going to like tip your hand a little bit. Is it tip your hand or tip your hat? Is tip your hat? No, I think it's your hand because you're playing poker and you tip it and people see your cards. Right, but you tip your hat for something else. A hello, maybe. But I thought you were going to hint at what Pam's big news was.
我们要开始了吗？速记事实第一条，我以为你会稍微透露一点。是“tip your hand”（泄露底牌）还是“tip your hat”（脱帽致意）？是“tip your hat”吗？不，我认为是“tip your hand”，因为你在玩扑克，你把它倾斜，人们就看到了你的牌。对，但你脱帽是为了别的事情。也许是打招呼。但我以为你要暗示帕姆的大新闻是什么。
But no, let's get into some fast facts. All right. Let's not tip anything. We're tipping nothing right now. Tip nothing. Fast fact number. Number one, I find it very funny that Paul had to write himself out of the show. I thought it was funny, too.
但不，让我们进入一些速记事实。好的。我们什么都别透露。我们现在什么都不透露。什么都不透露。速记事实第……第一条，我觉得保罗不得不把自己写出剧集非常有趣。我也觉得很有趣。
But knowing Paul, because he's very practical, it was probably like, well, it needs to be done. There is a very practical reason for why he wrote himself out of the show that we know. Paul and Jen are going to take over as the showrunners of the office starting in season five because Greg was going to be working on parks and recreation. Yep. Now, Greg was still around. He had a foot in both worlds. Yeah, he'd pop by, but he wasn't going to be there day to day.
但了解保罗，因为他非常务实，他可能觉得，好吧，这必须完成。我们知道他把自己写出剧集有一个非常实际的原因。珍和保罗将从第五季开始接手担任《办公室》的剧集主管，因为格雷格要去制作《公园与游憩》。是的。现在，格雷格还在。他两边都参与。是的，他会过来，但他不会每天都在那里。
That was Jen and Paul. So they teamed up to write this episode, and they were really trying to set themselves up for next season. Paul needed a break from the acting. He wanted to concentrate on writing the show. We traded emails with Paul, and he sent in an audio clip all about it. Jen Salada and I were taking over as showrunners for season five, and that was absolutely part of getting rid of me.
那是珍和保罗。所以他们联手写了这一集，他们真的在为下一季做准备。保罗需要从表演中休息一下。他想专注于编写剧集。我们和保罗互发了邮件，他发来了一段关于此的音频片段。珍·萨拉塔和我将接手担任第五季的剧集主管，这绝对是让我离开的原因之一。
Give me some time to just show run and concentrate on that. Did we know for a fact I'd be coming back? No, not for a fact. Didn't really think about it that far in. There was a lot of things started. Pam's acceptance to art school, that was something we had talked about for a long time. We always knew she liked it, but we were looking for, you know, a whole new complication after doing so much with the romance. And then Angela's engagement to Andy, we always knew that was not a relationship.
给我一些时间来担任剧集主管并专注于此。我们确定我会回来吗？不，不确定。没想那么远。有很多事情开始了。帕姆被艺术学校录取，那是我们谈论了很久的事情。我们一直知道她喜欢它，但在经历了这么多浪漫情节后，我们正在寻找一种全新的复杂情况。然后是安吉拉和安迪的订婚，我们一直知道那不是一段长久的关系。
to be. That was a bad relationship, a comedy relationship. But it gave us some fun stuff, obviously. There's so many big storylines that they set up with this finale. I know. I mean, we haven't even talked about Jan. That's part two. But my goodness. Oh, I know. Big, big, what do they call it? The cliffhanger. Big cliffhanger. Why am I having a hard time with like common phrases today? buckle in everybody because this might be a bumpy ride. Well, I'm here for it. I love when you mingle common phrases. It's one of my favorite things about you.
那是一段糟糕的关系，一段喜剧关系。但显然它给了我们一些有趣的东西。他们在这个大结局中设置了这么多重大的故事情节。我知道。我是说，我们甚至还没谈到简。那是第二部分。但天哪。哦，我知道。大大的，他们叫什么来着？悬念。大悬念。为什么我今天对常用短语感到困难？大家系好安全带，因为这可能是一段颠簸的旅程。好吧，我准备好了。我喜欢你混用常用短语。这是我最喜欢你的地方之一。
I don't know why. I almost said it's like the cliff's edge. And then in my brain, I was like, no, no, no, that's not right. You'll find it, lady. All right. Are you ready? Fast fact number two. Yeah.
我不知道为什么。我差点说成是悬崖边缘。然后在我的大脑里，我想，不，不，不，那不对。你会找到的，女士。好的。准备好了吗？速记事实第二条。是的。
Jen Salata said that this script took about five days to write. Five days. That's crazy. How did they do it in five days? Geez, it would take me so long to write this. This is a juggernaut. I know. She said they had an outline and they divided up the work and they each wrote different parts
珍·萨拉塔说这个剧本写了大约五天。五天。太疯狂了。他们是怎么在五天内完成的？天哪，我写这个要花很长时间。这是一个庞然大物。我知道。她说他们有一个大纲，分工合作，每个人写不同的部分
and then they put it all together and they did a rewrite together. So, I mean, I guess there were two people on it, but still. Also, the original cut of this episode came in at 72 minutes and they had to cut it down to 40 minutes. Lady, guess who found her shooting draft of Goodbye Toby! You, electronic hoarder. Yes, digital hoarder, Angela Kinsey. All right, Jenna, since I have this shooting draft of Goodbye, Toby, I have a little quiz for you. Oh.
然后他们把它们放在一起，一起进行了重写。所以，我是说，我想有两个人参与，但仍然。而且，这一集的原始剪辑时长为72分钟，他们不得不把它剪到40分钟。女士，猜猜谁找到了她的《再见，托比》拍摄草稿！你，电子囤积狂。是的，数字囤积狂，安吉拉·金赛。好的，珍娜，既然我有这份《再见，托比》的拍摄草稿，我要给你一个小测验。哦。
All right. You're like, I didn't know I was going to get tested today. Okay. Can you guess how many pages were in the shooting draft? Oh. Well, let me think. If I remember correctly, our standard shooting drafts were usually around 30. pages. Yep. So since this was a double episode, I'm going to say 60 pages. 75! Oh my gosh. Well, no wonder the
好的。你就像是，我不知道今天会被测试。好的。你能猜出拍摄草稿有多少页吗？哦。好吧，让我想想。如果我没记错的话，我们的标准拍摄草稿通常在30页左右。是的。所以既然这是双集，我要说60页。75！天哪。难怪
original cut came in at 72 minutes. I know. They always say each page of a script equals one minute of screen time. On average, right? Well, lady, there were so much on the page that did not make it in this episode. Well, I'm guessing there are a lot of deleted scenes. Oh, there's some, wonderful deleted scenes. And then there's even more scenes that aren't in the deleted scenes. I really enjoyed this. I'm going to sprinkle things throughout. And you know what? It really made me respect, Jenna? What? Our editors. I'll tell you why. I rewatched this episode four times. And one of the times I rewatched it, I just followed along in the script. And the scenes were moved all around in editing. I was fascinated by it. And it really just shows you what a
原始剪辑时长为72分钟。我知道。他们总是说剧本的每一页等于一分钟的屏幕时间。平均来说，对吧？好吧，女士，页面上有太多东西没有进入这一集。好吧，我猜有很多删减片段。哦，有一些很棒的删减片段。还有更多不在删减片段里的场景。我真的很享受这个。我会把东西散布在各处。你知道吗？它真的让我尊重，珍娜？什么？我们的剪辑师。我告诉你为什么。我重看了这一集四次。其中一次重看时，我只是跟着剧本看。场景在剪辑中被到处移动。我对此很着迷。它真的向你展示了
storytellers, our editors are. You know, I remember that, Angela. I remember that they would almost like rewrite the script again in the editing process. Yeah. Because they would do that. They would move scenes around from where they had been placed in the script originally. I love that. Well, are you ready for fast fact number three? Yeah. Fast fact number three, Amy Ryan, aka Holly Flacks, a.k.a. Michael's true love. Aw, I loved Holly Flax. I loved her. We had a fan question from Zianna G. Was Amy Ryan asked to play Holly, or did she have to go through the audition process?
我们的剪辑师是多么出色的讲故事的人。你知道，我记得那个，安吉拉。我记得他们几乎会在剪辑过程中再次重写剧本。是的。因为他们会那样做。他们会把场景从剧本最初放置的位置移走。我喜欢那个。好吧，准备好迎接速记事实第三条了吗？是的。速记事实第三条，艾米·瑞恩，也就是霍莉·弗拉克斯，也就是迈克尔的真爱。啊，我爱死霍莉·弗拉克斯了。我爱她。我们有一个来自齐安娜·G的粉丝问题。艾米·瑞恩是被邀请扮演霍莉的，还是她必须经过试镜过程？
Amy did not have to audition for the role of Holly Flax. It was offered to her, and this is why. First of all, Amy Ryan had just been nominated for an Academy Award. We had another Academy Award nominee on our show. She'd been nominated for a movie called Gone Baby Gone. And in addition to that, the writing staff of the office was slightly obsessed with the TV show The Wire. And Amy had been on the Wire. And whenever we had big guest star roles come up, the writers would try to get cast members from the Wire to do them.
艾米不需要为霍莉·弗拉克斯这个角色试镜。它是提供给她的，原因如下。首先，艾米·瑞恩刚刚获得了奥斯卡奖提名。我们的剧集中有另一位奥斯卡奖提名者。她因一部名为《失踪宝贝》的电影获得提名。此外，《办公室》的编剧团队对电视剧《火线》略显痴迷。而艾米曾出演过《火线》。每当有重要的客串角色出现时，编剧们都会尝试让《火线》的演员来扮演。
I mean, spoiler alert, Idraselba is coming up. Mm-hmm. But there is actually even more to this story, but we will let Paul Lieberstein tell you. Here's an audio clip from Paul where he also talks about their overall plans for the role of Holly. Amy Ryan, her agents were asking her, well, what do you want to do? And she said, I want to do the office. And at the very same time, we were talking about her. And I don't really know who reached out to who first.
我是说，剧透预警，伊德里斯·艾尔巴要来了。嗯哼。但这个故事其实还有更多内容，但我们会让保罗·利伯斯坦告诉你。这是保罗的一段音频片段，他也谈到了他们对霍莉这个角色的总体计划。艾米·瑞恩，她的经纪人问她，好吧，你想做什么？她说，我想做《办公室》。与此同时，我们也在谈论她。我真的不知道是谁先联系谁的。
I worked with Amy like a million years ago on another show, and we knew each other. her and I was I was all for it I loved working with her both times so we didn't know how much of an arc was it going to be with Amy we didn't really know we didn't have this kind of long-term deal we wanted to kind of test it out and see because you never know about chemistry right you never know if she's going to have chemistry with Steve and she sure did I don't think we knew that this was going to be the you know love of his life we we hadn't planned it that far and ahead We were also watching what happened and reacting to it. Can you believe that she said The Office?
我在一百万年前在另一部剧里和艾米合作过，我们认识。我和她，我全力支持。我两次都喜欢和她合作，所以我们不知道艾米会有多少戏份。我们真的不知道，我们没有这种长期合同，我们想测试一下看看，因为你永远不知道化学反应，对吧？你永远不知道她是否会和史蒂夫有化学反应，而她确实有。我不认为我们知道这将是，你知道，他生命中的挚爱，我们没有计划那么远。我们也在观察发生了什么并做出反应。你能相信她说《办公室》吗？
I was so tickled by that. I mean, she did this interview where she said she had been doing these heavy dramas. And she really wanted to lighten things up. She wanted to do a comedy and she loved our show. So that's what she told her agent she wanted to do. Here are her crossover the office connections. Jenna, she was not on Monk. Oh, no.
我被逗乐了。我是说，她做过一次采访，说她一直在演那些沉重的剧情片。她真的很想让事情轻松一点。她想演一部喜剧，她喜欢我们的剧。所以这就是她告诉她经纪人她想做的事。这是她与《办公室》的交叉联系。珍娜，她没演过《神探阿蒙》。哦，不。
She wasn't on Monk. But the show that her and Paul worked on was in the 90s, and it was called The Naked Truth with Taya Leone, and Paul Lieberstein was a writer on it. So that's where they met. And then she and Steve Correll did a movie together in 2007 called Dan in Real Life. So they had worked together before. Yes. Kentapedia told me that they had locked her down for six episodes for season five when she did this guest role. But that's as far as they went.
她没演过《神探阿蒙》。但她和保罗合作的那部剧是在90年代，叫《赤裸真相》，主演是蒂娅·里欧妮，保罗·利伯斯坦是那部剧的编剧。所以他们是在那里认识的。然后她和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在2007年合作了一部电影叫《老爸夏令营》。所以他们之前合作过。是的。肯塔百科告诉我，当她出演这个客串角色时，他们已经锁定了她出演第五季的六集。但这就是他们的计划。
And kind of like what Paul said, they didn't know if this was going to be a temporary love interest for Michael. They weren't sure, but they did have her set to start off the next season. There are so many great scenes between Holly and Michael in this episode. And there are even more wonderful ones in the script. I really wish they all could have stayed in. I know they had to trim them, but you really see the build of their sort of mutual, like, crush on each other. I got choked up watching this episode. Every time she returns his affection or flirts with him a little bit, I mean, I was so excited
就像保罗说的，他们不知道这是否会是迈克尔的临时恋人。他们不确定，但他们确实让她在下一季开始时就加入。这一集中霍莉和迈克尔之间有很多很棒的场景。剧本里还有更多精彩的场景。我真的很希望它们都能保留下来。我知道他们不得不删减，但你真的看到了他们那种相互吸引的建立过程。看这一集时我哽咽了。每次她回应他的爱慕或对他调情一点点，我是说，我为迈克尔感到如此兴奋
for Michael that a woman was being kind to him. I mean, I was emotional. Not just kind, but she gets him. They have the same humor. Yes. Well, lady, that's all I got. Should we take a break? And then we'll come back and get into this episode.
有一个女人对他很好。我是说，我很激动。不仅是好，而且她懂他。他们有同样的幽默感。是的。好吧，女士，这就是我所有的内容了。我们要休息一下吗？然后我们会回来进入这一集。
Let's do it. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve. Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. BetterHelp makes therapy accessible and flexible.
让我们开始吧。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，我们要花点时间来赞美女性以及她们在工作、人际关系、家庭以及她们每天扮演的许多角色中所承担的一切。我们需要提醒自己我们有多重要，治疗为我们提供了一个空间，让我们以应有的方式照顾自己。治疗也可以是一个设定界限和建立自信的地方。为了改变，照顾好你自己的幸福。BetterHelp让治疗变得可及且灵活。
Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S. and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works, with an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at betterhelp.com slash office ladies.
他们的治疗师在美国拥有完全执照，并遵循严格的行为准则。拥有超过30,000名治疗师，BetterHelp是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，而且它很有效，基于超过170万条客户评论，现场会议的平均评分为4.9/5。你的情绪健康很重要。在治疗中寻找支持并感到轻松。注册并在betterhelp.com/officeladies获得10%的折扣。
That's better help.com slash office ladies. All right, we are back with a classic gym prank. This is our cold open and Michael is not in it. Did you notice? I did notice. His door is shut. We're being led to believe that Steve is behind that door, but he was not. He was probably prepping for a film.
那是betterhelp.com/officeladies。好的，我们带着经典的吉姆恶作剧回来了。这是我们的冷开场，迈克尔不在里面。你注意到了吗？我注意到了。他的门关着。我们被引导相信史蒂夫在门后，但他不在。他可能在为电影做准备。
Or maybe finally getting to sleep in for a second. Oh my gosh, having the morning off. I hope he had the morning off. Dwight's cell phone rang. and somehow Jim answers it on his little Bluetooth thing and his, you know, his ear. Do you remember those? Yes, and people would walk around with them. Yeah, I mean, we kind of still have this like earbud thing that we do.
或者也许终于可以睡个懒觉了。天哪，早上休息。我希望他早上休息。德怀特的手机响了。不知何故，吉姆在他的小蓝牙设备上接听了，在他的，你知道，他的耳朵里。你还记得那些吗？是的，人们会带着它们走来走去。是的，我是说，我们现在还有这种耳塞式的东西。
But back in the day, y'all, those things were giant. Did you see how big that thing was on Jim's ear? This is an old tech alert for sure. And it is starting to drive Dwight crazy. Why are all of his calls going to Jim? Jim explains that Dwight left his cell phone on his desk. So naturally, he paired it to his headset. But it goes on.
但在过去，伙计们，那些东西是巨大的。你看到吉姆耳朵上那个东西有多大吗？这绝对是一个旧技术警报。而且它开始让德怀特发疯了。为什么他所有的电话都转到了吉姆那里？吉姆解释说德怀特把手机忘在桌子上了。所以自然地，他把它配对到了他的耳机上。但还没完。
Dwight's like, fine. Then I'm going to reprogram my cell phone to go to my desk. Well, Jim took care of that too. He forwarded Dwight's desk phone to his desk phone. You know, I'm probably going to get some hate for this, but it does make me feel like Ryan was correct in sort of calling Jim out on his productivity. because look at all the effort he went into this whole like earpiece prank. And he probably could have made some sales during this time.
德怀特说，好吧。那我要把我的手机重新编程到我的桌子上。好吧，吉姆也处理了那个。他把德怀特的座机转接到了他的座机上。你知道，我可能会因此受到一些抨击，但这确实让我觉得瑞安在某种程度上指责吉姆的生产力是正确的。因为看看他为这个整个耳机恶作剧付出的努力。他在这段时间里可能已经完成了一些销售。
Here's what I want to say about that because I worked in corporate America for a long time. And I often felt like I could get all of my work done in about five hours, but I was required to sit there for eight. Yeah. I mean, sometimes you can get what needs to be done faster than the company has allotted. And so I think that was the case with Jim. I think he does very good in sales. I don't know.
这就是我想说的，因为我在企业界工作了很长时间。我经常觉得我可以在大约五个小时内完成我所有的工作，但我被要求坐在那里八个小时。是的。我是说，有时你可以比公司分配的时间更快地完成需要做的事情。所以我认为吉姆就是这种情况。我认为他在销售方面做得很好。我不知道。
I guess Ryan was like, what if you really spent those extra hours making sales? But I don't know. He's getting it done. And he's, I mean, sometimes I feel like these work hours are rather arbitrary. How about work until your work is done and then go home and enjoy your life? I like that. Jenna, you sound like some upstart company where you're like, here's the thing.
我猜瑞安的意思是，如果你真的把那些额外的时间花在销售上会怎样？但我不知道。他完成了。而且他，我是说，有时我觉得这些工作时间相当随意。工作到你的工作完成，然后回家享受你的生活怎么样？我喜欢那个。珍娜，你听起来像某个初创公司，你说，事情是这样的。
Everyone gets pockets. Yes. You work as long as you want. Get your shit done. We don't care. Also, we have a soapbox in the lobby and you can stand on it at any point in your day if you need to make any declarations about anything. Yeah, and finally, we have like a zombie apocalypse shelter ready to go. Yeah, we have a panic room totally stocked.
每个人都有口袋。是的。你想工作多久就工作多久。把你的事做完。我们不在乎。此外，我们在大厅里有一个肥皂箱，如果你需要对任何事情发表任何声明，你可以在一天中的任何时候站在上面。是的，最后，我们有一个僵尸末日避难所准备好了。是的，我们有一个完全储备的紧急避难室。
That's Jenna's company. Who wants to work for me? Come work for me. That sounds amazing. You know what? It's funny. I've basically created that job with this podcast. You have.
那是珍娜的公司。谁想为我工作？来为我工作吧。听起来太棒了。你知道吗？很有趣。我基本上通过这个播客创造了那份工作。你确实创造了。
You've given yourself all of those things, except maybe the zombie apocalypse room. I don't know. Do you have a... Wait, is there something you need to tell me? I don't have a whole room, but I've got all my backpacks ready to go. I have a catch for this cold open. It's a Jenna catch. During this cold open, Jim pretends to talk to Dwight's mother.
你给了自己所有那些东西，除了也许僵尸末日室。我不知道。你有一个……等等，有什么你需要告诉我的吗？我没有整个房间，但我所有的背包都准备好了。我为这个冷开场有一个发现。这是一个珍娜发现。在这个冷开场中，吉姆假装和德怀特的母亲说话。
Yeah. Right? He says, mutter, tell Fatter I'm getting married. Yeah. Well, in Fun Run, do you remember, Angela? When Dwight is trying to make your character feel better about Sprinkles dying, he offers to have sprinkles stuffed, or he offers to have sprinkles buried in the East Field by mother.
是的。对吧？他说，妈妈，告诉爸爸我要结婚了。是的。好吧，在《趣味跑》里，你还记得吗，安吉拉？当德怀特试图让你的角色对斯普林克尔斯的死感觉好一点时，他提议把斯普林克尔斯做成标本，或者他提议让斯普林克尔斯被母亲埋在东边的田野里。
Yeah. Dwight's mother is not living. Yeah. Little continuity error. Yes, I was very proud of my catch. Well done, Jenna. Guess what? What?
是的。德怀特的母亲不在了。是的。小小的连续性错误。是的，我为我的发现感到非常自豪。干得好，珍娜。猜猜怎么着？什么？
It's Toby's last day. Michael is dancing through the office. He's gotten there so early. No one is there, and he's literally dancing. I mean, he says, today is one of those days. You know you will remember for the rest of your life. I know. It's a countdown until his horribleness is out of the building.
是托比的最后一天。迈克尔在办公室里跳舞。他到得很早。没人，他真的在跳舞。我是说，他说，今天是那些你知道你余生都会记得的日子之一。我知道。这是他那令人讨厌的人离开大楼的倒计时。
He sets an alarm on his watch. Mm-hmm. That's going to go off as Toby has his final moments in the office. He's so excited. He's giddy. Toby arrives. He goes back to HR and Kelly hugs him. She can't believe it's his last day.
他在手表上设了一个闹钟。嗯哼。当托比在办公室度过最后时刻时，它会响。他太兴奋了。他头晕目眩。托比到了。他回到人力资源部，凯利拥抱了他。她不敢相信这是他的最后一天。
She feels so weird. Toby feels fine. He's not a lot. upset. Yeah. All right, conference room meeting, Angela. The party planning committee is going to discuss Toby's goodbye party. I loved every minute of this scene. I loved every minute of doing it. I loved every minute of watching it. I am so very pregnant. I'm at that stage in pregnancy where you can't hide it. Look at my face. No, your belly is practically in your neck. Let's be honest. I don't know how you fit under that table. I'm a short person, you guys. Tall people when they're pregnant, they go up. But when you're
她感觉很奇怪。托比感觉很好。他没有太难过。是的。好的，会议室会议，安吉拉。派对策划委员会要讨论托比的欢送派对。我喜欢这个场景的每一分钟。我喜欢表演它的每一分钟。我喜欢看它的每一分钟。我怀孕了。我处于怀孕的那个阶段，你无法隐藏它。看我的脸。不，你的肚子几乎在你的脖子里。老实说。我不知道你是怎么塞进那张桌子底下的。我是一个矮个子，伙计们。高个子怀孕时，他们向上长。但当你
short, you just go out. And it was like my head was sitting on top of my belly. Angela tells Michael, here's what they've got for the party. A buttercream cake and a slideshow of Toby, but they only have two photos of Toby. They're just two different expressions standing, getting coffee in the kitchen. It's amazing. Michael is like, absolutely not. No, no, no. This needs to be very special. Toby is going away forever. He wants the party to end all parties. Yeah, he says when someone in New Orleans leaves, they throw a parade for them. And Pam says, you want to throw Toby a New Orleans funeral? Because that's what that means. That's the parade Michael is talking about. In the shooting draft, Jenna, there were a few more extra lines to the scene that really tickled me.
矮的时候，你只是向外长。就像我的头坐在我的肚子上一样。安吉拉告诉迈克尔，这是他们为派对准备的东西。一个奶油蛋糕和托比的幻灯片，但他们只有两张托比的照片。它们只是在厨房里站着、喝咖啡的两个不同表情。太棒了。迈克尔说，绝对不行。不，不，不。这需要非常特别。托比要永远离开了。他想要一个空前绝后的派对。是的，他说当新奥尔良有人离开时，他们会为他们举行游行。帕姆说，你想为托比举行新奥尔良葬礼吗？因为那就是那个意思。那是迈克尔在说的游行。在拍摄草稿中，珍娜，这个场景还有一些额外的台词，真的逗乐了我。
So Pam says that line. And then Michael says, if that's appropriate, then that's what I want. I want something that says, oh, wow, okay, oh God, thank God. And then Angela says, a prayer, you want a prayer party? And then that's when Michael says, if the devil were to explode and evil disappeared. That's what he says in the script. That's the kind of party I want to throw. Angela explains they only have enough money for a cake and maybe to develop a few more slides. Toby will not be in them. And that That is when Michael gets out his shoe. As one does, you get out your shoe, you pull up the insult, and you have a lot of cash.
所以帕姆说了那句台词。然后迈克尔说，如果那很合适，那这就是我想要的。我想要一些能表达“哦，哇，好的，哦上帝，谢天谢地”的东西。然后安吉拉说，祈祷，你想要一个祈祷派对？然后迈克尔说，如果魔鬼爆炸了，邪恶消失了。他在剧本里就是这么说的。那就是我想举办的那种派对。安吉拉解释说他们只有足够的钱买蛋糕，也许还能多洗几张幻灯片。托比不会在里面。而那就是迈克尔拿出他的鞋子的时候。就像一个人做的那样，你拿出你的鞋子，你拉出侮辱，你有很多现金。
Yeah. Michael explains every year his grandma sends him $50 for his birthday, but lately she's been sending him about nine or ten checks a year. He was saving for a motorcycle, Angela, but he thinks this is what he wants to spend his money on. We had a fan question from Isabella D. In Catcher in the Rye, Holden says that his loaded grandmother, has been losing her marbles a little bit and has been sending him money for his birthday multiple times a year. Was this a happy coincidence or an intentional reference? And who came up with it? I don't know. Do you know? I found out. Paul wrote this. He said it was not intentional.
是的。迈克尔解释说他奶奶每年在他生日时寄给他50美元，但最近她一年寄给他九或十张支票。他本来在存钱买摩托车，安吉拉，但他认为这就是他想花钱的地方。我们有一个来自伊莎贝拉·D的粉丝问题。在《麦田里的守望者》中，霍尔顿说他那富有的祖母，有点失去理智了，每年在他生日时多次寄钱给他。这是一个快乐的巧合还是一个故意的引用？是谁想出来的？我不知道。你知道吗？我发现了。保罗写的。他说这不是故意的。
It's just a happy coincidence. But I would like to say, Isabella D. Applaud. I applaud you for being very, very well read. Yes. And bringing up this literary parallel reference. Yeah. Well, Michael starts listing all of these ridiculous things he wants at this party. He says he wants to feel like he's flying through the air without this ugly weight holding him down. He wants an anti-gravity machine. And you know what? Angela has had it. She has had it. She said she doesn't want us foot money. Oh, that made me laugh out loud, lady. I loved foot money. I mean, I laughed out loud. You know, in the script, Jenna, I looked, because I was curious about the direction. of the scene. And it says that Angela pushes the money back towards Michael. And I added that I did it
这只是一个快乐的巧合。但我还是想说，伊莎贝拉·D。鼓掌。我为你读过很多书而鼓掌。是的。并提出了这个文学平行引用。是的。好吧，迈克尔开始列出他想要在这个派对上拥有的所有荒谬的东西。他说他想感觉自己像在空中飞翔，没有这个丑陋的重物压着他。他想要一台反重力机器。你知道吗？安吉拉受够了。她受够了。她说她不想要脚钱。哦，那让我大声笑了出来，女士。我喜欢脚钱。我是说，我大声笑了出来。你知道，在剧本里，珍娜，我看了，因为我对场景的指导很好奇。它说安吉拉把钱推回给迈克尔。我加了我是用
with my pen. That was me. That's what I loved about it. You didn't even want to touch it. No. It disgusted you so much. Yeah. But it was so fun. I remember us getting really tickled, Jenna. Oh my gosh. We loved these scenes with Steve and the party planning committee. They are truly some of my favorite to shoot. Yeah, it was just candy. It didn't feel like work. I just couldn't wait. And my biggest goal was just to not laugh so that we could get some usable footage. Well, now Michael is going to put Phyllis in charge. I loved it so much. Phyllis crushed it.
我的笔做的。那是我。这就是我喜欢它的地方。你甚至不想碰它。不。它让你感到如此恶心。是的。但这太有趣了。我记得我们真的很开心，珍娜。天哪。我们喜欢这些史蒂夫和派对策划委员会的场景。它们确实是我最喜欢拍摄的场景之一。是的，那就像糖果。感觉不像工作。我只是等不及了。我最大的目标就是不笑，这样我们就能得到一些可用的素材。好吧，现在迈克尔要让菲利斯负责。我太喜欢了。菲利斯做得太棒了。
The way she said yes. When Michael asks her if she will plan the party, it is like she has waited for this moment her whole life. So I have a little script tidbit to share. After Phyllis says yes, it would have cut immediately to an Angela talking head. And it says Angela's talking head just starts with a huge fake laugh. And then Angela says, I was going to let Phyllis be in charge of cups today. And even then, I had a stack of cups standing by in my trunk.
她说“是”的方式。当迈克尔问她是否会策划派对时，就像她一生都在等待这一刻。所以我有一个小剧本花絮要分享。在菲利斯说“是”之后，它本应立即切到一个安吉拉的采访。它说安吉拉的采访只是以一个巨大的假笑开始。然后安吉拉说，我今天本来要让菲利斯负责杯子的。即使那样，我也在后备箱里准备了一叠杯子。
Of course you did. That's so good. They must have just loved writing those snarky talking heads for you, Angela. They're so good. I was going to let her be in charge of cups. Sort of. But I doubt she could handle it. Well, now the big moment.
你当然准备了。那太好了。他们一定很喜欢为你写那些刻薄的采访，安吉拉。它们太棒了。我本来要让她负责杯子的。算是吧。但我怀疑她能否处理好。好吧，现在是重要时刻。
Holly Flacks arrives, new HR rep. Yes, and Toby has a talking head that as part of his last day, he's going to be training the new human resources rep. And he says, again, the company has allotted only one day for this one training day. That's all you need. That's it? Yeah. That's all you're going to say about this moment in the show.
霍莉·弗拉克斯到了，新的人力资源代表。是的，托比有一个采访，作为他最后一天的一部分，他要培训新的人力资源代表。他说，同样，公司只分配了一天时间进行这次培训。这就是你所需要的。就这些？是的。这就是你要说的关于剧集中这一刻的全部内容吗？
What? What are you hinting at? I can't believe I have to bring this up. Lady, what? The blooming plant at reception? Hold up with your shade, Jenna Fisher. I have a whole plant breakdown. I was going to bring up later.
什么？你在暗示什么？我不敢相信我不得不提起这个。女士，什么？接待处那盆开花的植物？珍娜·费舍尔，收起你的阴阳怪气。我有一个完整的植物分析。我本来打算稍后提起的。
Thank you very much. I was going to let Holly have her moment. Oh, all right. Well, I shouldn't have doubted you. I'm sorry. Don't doubt me. But I mean, all I saw was a blooming plant at reception. She's carrying a plant in her box.
非常感谢。我本来打算让霍莉有她的时刻。哦，好吧。好吧，我不该怀疑你的。对不起。别怀疑我。但我是说，我看到的只是接待处的一盆开花植物。她盒子里带着一盆植物。
It was just like a plant explosion. And as I was watching this episode, I thought, well, Angela's just going to love that. So many plants. I did not notice the plant in her box. She has a plant in her box? She has a plant in her box. How many times are we going to say plant in her box? Hashtag plant in her box.
就像植物爆炸一样。当我看这一集时，我想，好吧，安吉拉会喜欢那个的。这么多植物。我没注意到她盒子里的植物。她盒子里有一盆植物？她盒子里有一盆植物。我们要说多少次“她盒子里有植物”？标签：她盒子里有植物。
It sounds dirty. Is that just me? No, it's not just you. But I kind of like it. I like it. Be like, hey, how was last night? Did you get a plant in your box? Is that too much?
听起来很脏。只有我这么觉得吗？不，不只是你。但我有点喜欢它。我喜欢它。就像，嘿，昨晚怎么样？你盒子里有植物吗？那太过分了吗？
I want you to know if you go down there, I have a plant in my box. Oh, my gosh. What are we even talking about right now? We don't even know what we're talking about. We just know we're going to get the E. Oh, my gosh. Okay, wait, since we're bringing up plant, I might as well do my plant breakdown here, lady.
我想让你知道如果你去那里，我盒子里有一盆植物。天哪。我们现在到底在说什么？我们甚至不知道我们在说什么。我们只知道我们要得到E。天哪。好吧，等等，既然我们提到了植物，我不如在这里做我的植物分析，女士。
Here's the thing. That is a very tall blooming plant. Two shades of pink. It's the happiest plant I've ever seen at front reception. I think I could be wrong, but I think they're gerber daisies. My plant people, I want to hear from you. What are these plants? Pam has a blooming plant in her box.
事情是这样的。那是一盆非常高的开花植物。两种深浅的粉红色。这是我在前台见过的最快乐的植物。我想我可能错了，但我认为它们是非洲菊。我的植物专家们，我想听听你们的意见。这些是什么植物？帕姆的盒子里有一盆开花植物。
Pam is the happiest she's ever been. Yeah. And her plant is reflecting that. Now, it won't live past this week. She's going to have a dead plant in her box later. Oh, dear. You don't want a dead plant in your box, everyone. Well, here is why Pam is so happy, everyone.
帕姆是她有史以来最快乐的时候。是的。她的植物反映了这一点。现在，它活不过这周。她以后盒子里会有一盆死植物。哦，亲爱的。大家，你可不想盒子里有一盆死植物。好吧，这就是为什么帕姆这么快乐，各位。
And it's why her plant is blooming. She gets a very exciting email. and she is going to rush to the break room to tell Jim, he's just sitting there having some chips in a soda, just tracking, again, not working. Yeah. So far today, he's played a prank and he needs a chip break. Mm-hmm.
这就是为什么她的植物在开花。她收到了一封非常令人兴奋的电子邮件。她要冲到休息室告诉吉姆，他正坐在那里吃薯片喝汽水，只是在追踪，再次强调，没在工作。是的。今天到目前为止，他搞了一个恶作剧，他需要休息一下吃薯片。嗯哼。
Busy day for Jim. She tells Jim, she has been accepted to the Pratt School of Design for their three-month program. Yeah, I titled this scene, Happiness in the Break Room. She's really happy, but she's going to have to go to New York for three months. That's a long time.
吉姆忙碌的一天。她告诉吉姆，她被普拉特设计学院的三个月课程录取了。是的，我把这个场景命名为“休息室里的幸福”。她真的很开心，但她将不得不去纽约三个月。那是一段很长的时间。
It's not that long. It feels like forever. No, I'm kidding. Jim says it's no big deal. They'll just visit one another. He's being incredibly supportive. It's super, super swoony and wonderful. I went to the Pratt website because I want you to know how significant it is that Pam got accepted to this school.
没那么长。感觉像永远。不，我在开玩笑。吉姆说这没什么大不了的。他们会互相探望的。他非常支持。超级，超级令人心动和美妙。我去了普拉特网站，因为我想让你知道帕姆被这所学校录取是多么重要。
Oh, let's hear it. It is listed as the 10th best art and design school in the world in 2020. The 10th, it's number 10th. It's number 10. So it just barely made it in. Oh my God. Angela Kinsey. I'm kidding.
哦，让我们听听。它在2020年被列为世界第10大艺术与设计学院。第10，它是第10。它是第10。所以它勉强挤进去了。天哪。安吉拉·金赛。我在开玩笑。
I'm kidding. Let me tell you the other schools in the United States that made the list above Pratt. Oh, my God. Listen to her. Listen to the staff. I'm sorry of being so sassy. Oh my gosh. Pratt people, I'm very proud of you.
我在开玩笑。让我告诉你美国其他排在普拉特之上的学校。天哪。听听她。听听员工。抱歉我这么刻薄。天哪。普拉特的人们，我为你们感到非常自豪。
I think this is a huge achievement. All right. Well, here are some other great art and design schools in the United States. Parsons, Project Runway, anyone? Tim Gunn, hello? Make it work. Rhode Island School of Design, MIT, and the School of Art Institute of Chicago. Those were the other ones.
我认为这是一个巨大的成就。好吧。好吧，这里还有一些美国其他伟大的艺术与设计学校。帕森斯，有人看过《天桥风云》吗？蒂姆·冈恩，你好？让它成功。罗德岛设计学院，麻省理工学院，以及芝加哥艺术学院。那些是其他的。
But how about this? Since you're down on its number 10 ranking, I am not down on it. I just was playing around. Well, in 2021, I found a list where it jumped to number four. Well, good job. How about that? But listen to this part. Uh-oh.
但是这个怎么样？既然你对它排名第10不满意，我倒不觉得。我只是随便说说。好吧，在2021年，我发现了一个榜单，它跃升到了第四名。好吧，干得好。那怎么样？但听听这一部分。噢，不。
As I was reading these lists of schools and their credentials, there's a part of it where they talk about the average early wages of a graduate from art school. I found this fascinating. As an artist, as actors ourselves, right? The average yearly wages are around $40,000 a year. Out of college. Out of college. Okay.
当我阅读这些学校及其资质的列表时，其中有一部分谈到了艺术学校毕业生的平均早期工资。我觉得这很迷人。作为艺术家，作为我们自己也是演员，对吧？平均年薪大约是每年4万美元。刚出校门。刚出校门。好吧。
But this led me to wanting to speak about the average wages of an actor. You guys, Jenna just got out her book that she wrote. We'll put in our stories where you can buy it. She's going to quote herself from her book. Yes, that's right. I'm holding my own book that I wrote. It is called The Actors Life, a Survival Guide. I was not expecting this to become a book plug, but there you go.
但这让我想要谈谈演员的平均工资。伙计们，珍娜刚拿出了她写的书。我们会把购买链接放在我们的故事里。她要引用她书里的话。是的，没错。我拿着我自己写的书。它叫《演员的生活，生存指南》。我没料到这会变成书的广告，但就是这样。
I'm going to now quote myself. You quote yourself, lady. I'm here for it. How badass is it that I'm about to quote myself from my own book? I'm sorry. That's kind of amazing. I mean, I would love to take a screen grab of you right now. It's adorable.
我现在要引用我自己的话。你引用你自己，女士。我支持你。我要引用我自己书里的话，这有多酷？抱歉。这真是太棒了。我的意思是，我现在真想给你截个屏。太可爱了。
And then I'll put a swipe up in our stories, Jenna, on where you can get your book, which is a fantastic book for anyone who's making a way and whatever your form of art is. It's a great, great book. Well, here, as I quote myself, I did some research on the average wages of an actor in general. And according to the Screen Actress Guild, which is the union the actors belong to, the median income for a working actor is $52,000 a year. But most of the SAG after membership earns less than $7,000 a year from acting. And only 5% of union actors earn more than $100,000 a year.
然后我会把链接放在我们的故事里，珍娜，关于在哪里可以买到你的书，这对任何正在努力奋斗、无论从事何种艺术形式的人来说都是一本很棒的书。这是一本非常非常好的书。好吧，在这里，当我引用我自己的话时，我做了一些关于演员平均工资的研究。根据演员工会（SAG），也就是演员所属的工会，职业演员的收入中位数是每年5.2万美元。但大多数SAG会员每年的演艺收入不到7000美元。只有5%的工会演员每年收入超过10万美元。
But I did more math. I really break it down in the book. Because I said, let's pretend that you earn that median income of $52,000 a year from acting. you don't get to keep it because you have to pay agent commissions, manager commissions, taxes. So I calculated the average take-home pay per year of a working union actor, and it is $29,000 a year. If you're lucky. If you're lucky. Yeah. That's right. Listen, the artist's journey is not one that you do for money. You do it because you love to do it. It's because it's your passion and you feel like you couldn't do anything else, you know?
但我做了更多的计算。我在书里真的把它拆解了。因为我说，假设你从演艺中获得了5.2万美元的收入中位数。你拿不到那么多，因为你必须支付经纪人佣金、经理佣金、税款。所以我计算了职业工会演员每年的平均实得工资，是每年2.9万美元。如果你幸运的话。如果你幸运的话。是的。没错。听着，艺术家的旅程不是为了钱而做的。你做它是为了你热爱它。是因为它是你的激情所在，你觉得你做不了别的，你知道吗？
And so you have to have your eyes wide open. If you go into work as an artist, that you're doing it for the love of the art. And if you buy Jenna's book, you'll also get to see her early headshots, which are really a delight. And so many of them, I'm wearing overalls for a reason I can't explain. That was a thing. All right, let's get back to the episode. Moving on, Michael and Dwight are peering out of. Michael's office and they're looking on as Toby introduces Holly to Stanley, Michael hates her.
所以你必须睁大眼睛。如果你作为一名艺术家去工作，你是为了对艺术的热爱而做。如果你买了珍娜的书，你还能看到她早期的头像照，那真是令人愉悦。而且其中很多，我穿着背带裤，原因我无法解释。那曾经是一种潮流。好了，让我们回到剧集。继续，迈克尔和德怀特正从迈克尔的办公室往外看，他们看着托比向斯坦利介绍霍莉，迈克尔讨厌她。
He hates her. Dwight hates her head. Yeah. Doesn't like how her head is. Dwight says it's an odd shape, right? And Michael thinks Dwight just says things to agree with him, but he does say, all right, fine, her head is weird. And then Michael says we should sell her an elevator pass. And Dwight's like, but our elevator doesn't require, hazing. Hazing.
他讨厌她。德怀特讨厌她的头。是的。不喜欢她的头型。德怀特说形状很奇怪，对吧？迈克尔认为德怀特只是为了附和他才这么说，但他确实说，好吧，好吧，她的头确实很奇怪。然后迈克尔说我们应该卖给她一张电梯通行证。德怀特说，但我们的电梯不需要，欺凌。欺凌。
This is going to kick off a whole storyline for Dwight. Dwight is going to really lean into this idea of hazing, Holly. Oh, yeah. Dwight's on a mission now. You know, he loves having a call to action. Meanwhile, Phyllis is trying to find an anti-gravity machine. So far, she's only found someone who can connect her to antidepressants. I'm telling you, I have a catch at 7 minutes, 39 seconds.
这将开启德怀特的一整条故事线。德怀特真的会沉浸在欺凌霍莉这个想法中。哦，是的。德怀特现在有任务了。你知道，他喜欢有行动号召。与此同时，菲利斯正在试图寻找一台反重力机器。到目前为止，她只找到了一个能帮她联系抗抑郁药的人。我告诉你，我在7分39秒处有一个发现。
Phyllis is about to break when the lady on the phone says antidepressants. You can see her starting to laugh. We had a fan question about this, Angela, from Haley S. Corin T. Rose P. and Joe S. They said, who is she talking to on the phone? Because many of them think it sounds like Amy Ryan. They were like, did Amy Ryan fill in as the woman on the phone? No, she did not. I asked Kentipedia about this.
菲利斯正要崩溃时，电话那头的女士说了抗抑郁药。你可以看到她开始笑了。安吉拉，我们有一个关于这个的粉丝问题，来自海莉·S、科林·T、罗斯·P和乔·S。他们说，她在电话里和谁说话？因为他们很多人觉得听起来像艾米·瑞恩。他们问，是艾米·瑞恩客串了电话里的那个女人吗？不，她没有。我问了肯特百科关于这件事。
He said that we auditioned seven women to do this voiceover. He's pretty sure that we went with actress Molly Hagen. I could not find this part credited anywhere online, but I will tell you, if you saw Molly Hagen, you would recognize her. She's this brilliant, comedic actress. I'd also like to point out she's been on Monk. Oh, no way. Yeah.
他说我们试镜了七个女人来做这个配音。他很确定我们最终选择了女演员莫莉·哈根。我在网上任何地方都找不到这个角色的演职员表，但我可以告诉你，如果你看到莫莉·哈根，你一定会认出她。她是一位才华横溢的喜剧女演员。我还想指出她曾出演过《神探阿蒙》。哦，不会吧。是的。
I mean, Molly Hagan is like such a fantastic character actress. Like, if we got her, we were so lucky. I know. Folks out there listening, I want you to know there are many, many more delicious deleted Phyllis scenes as she tries to play on this party. So many, but I would like to play one of my favorites for you now. It's from the DVD. It's a scene between Kevin and Phyllis and then, of course, a little bit of Angela Sass at the end. Yes.
我的意思是，莫莉·哈根是一位非常出色的性格演员。如果能请到她，我们真是太幸运了。我知道。听众朋友们，我想让你们知道，还有很多很多美味的菲利斯删减片段，关于她试图策划这个派对。太多了，但我现在想为你播放我最喜欢的一个。它来自DVD。这是凯文和菲利斯之间的一场戏，当然，最后还有一点安吉拉的讽刺。是的。
Good news, Phil. The band just had a last-minute cancellation. So we are available to play at the going away party tonight. No way. Do what you guys did at my wedding? That wasn't me, fellas. That was Chester on bass. I'm talking about 30 police songs in a row, all off key, off temple,
好消息，菲尔。乐队刚刚临时取消了。所以我们今晚可以去告别派对上演奏。不会吧。做你们在我婚礼上做的那样？那不是我，菲利斯。那是切斯特在弹贝斯。我说的是连续30首警察乐队的歌，全部走调，节奏不对，
and you forgot at least half the lyrics. But, Phyllis, that was Scranticity. Day work. Now, I am with Scranticity, too. Give me a break. Fine, fellas. I'm sorry that I ruined your wedding. I didn't mean Kev. Kevin.
而且你至少忘了一半的歌词。但是，菲利斯，那是“Scranticity”。那是工作。现在，我和“Scranticity”在一起，太。饶了我吧。好吧，伙计们。很抱歉我毁了你们的婚礼。我不是那个意思，凯文。凯文。
Nice job. Real nice. Thank you. I didn't mean it. Really? You didn't mean it? Oh my God. So many great details about Phyllis's wedding. 30 police songs in a row. Off-key, off-tempo. They didn't know all the words. That would be horrible. my gosh. And then I pop in at the end. And Jenna, for this scene, I remember filming it because I'm
干得好。真不错。谢谢。我不是那个意思。真的吗？你不是那个意思？天哪。关于菲利斯婚礼的细节太多了。连续30首警察乐队的歌。走调，节奏不对。他们不知道所有的歌词。那太可怕了。天哪。然后我在最后冒出来。珍娜，对于这场戏，我记得拍摄过程，因为我
supposed to walk into the conference room like I overheard, like way to go, but they couldn't hide my belly. So they had me snuggle up to the wall and then lean, like lean my head around the corner. It was so awkward. And on set that day was an NBC photographer and he was in the conference room and he took this picture of me leaning around the corner. And lady, it's the photo they used on so many things and I'm so clearly pregnant. I'm like, this photo, this is the day you're going to take my picture? I'm going to put it in stories. I can't believe it. Whenever I see it, I'm like, really? There's no other photos. This was the photo. This will live forever. Great. Fantastic. Congratulations. Thank you. Well, now Toby is going to bring Holly to meet Michael.
应该走进会议室，就像我无意中听到了，就像干得好，但他们藏不住我的肚子。所以他们让我蜷缩在墙边，然后探身，就像把头探过拐角。太尴尬了。那天片场有一位NBC摄影师，他在会议室里，他拍下了我探过拐角的照片。天哪，这是他们用在很多地方的照片，我明显怀孕了。我心想，这张照片，这就是你要拍我的日子吗？我要把它发到故事里。我简直不敢相信。每当我看到它，我就想，真的吗？没有别的照片了吗？就是这张。这张照片将永远存在。太棒了。太好了。恭喜。谢谢。好吧，现在托比要带霍莉去见迈克尔。
Michael is so annoyed. Yeah. Now he's got to deal with female He says, listen, my job is to make the office fun. Your job is to make the office lame. Only one of us can win. He's basically like newsflash. It's going to be me. And then Holly throws him a total curveball. She turns to Toby and is like, what did you do to him? And Toby's like nothing. And Michael's like, no, he tortured me with his awfulness. And then Holly's like, yeah, I know what you mean. I nearly fell asleep when he gave me a tour of the files. Michael is thrown. He has met his person. I know.
迈克尔很烦。是的。现在他得应付女性。他说，听着，我的工作是让办公室变得有趣。你的工作是让办公室变得无聊。我们中只有一个能赢。他基本上是在说，新闻快报。那个人会是我。然后霍莉给了他一个完全的曲线球。她转向托比说，你对他做了什么？托比说没什么。迈克尔说，不，他用他的糟糕折磨我。然后霍莉说，是的，我明白你的意思。当他带我参观档案室时，我差点睡着了。迈克尔惊呆了。他遇到了他的知音。我知道。
And it's crazy. It's two sentences. And he's in love. All of a sudden, she is the most attractive, wonderful woman he's ever met. He has this great talking head where he says, you know what? Thanks to Toby, he believed that the HR department was a breeding ground for monsters. But what he failed to realize was that not all monsters are bad, like E.T. Is Holly their E.T.?
这太疯狂了。就两句话。他就坠入爱河了。突然之间，她是她见过最迷人、最棒的女人。他有一个很棒的采访片段，他说，你知道吗？多亏了托比，他曾认为人力资源部是怪物的滋生地。但他没意识到的是，并非所有的怪物都是坏的，比如E.T.。霍莉是他们的E.T.吗？
Yeah. Is Holly our extraterrestrial? Yeah. She's just an awesome woman from this planet. Oh my gosh. Well, Holly is going to keep making the rounds. She's going to keep meeting people in the office. But before we do that, should we take a quick break? Yes, because I texted Creed about the moment that Creed meets Holly. And I'll share that when we come back. Yay, I love it. All right, we are back. There is a fantastic scene between Creed and Holly where Holly's like, hey, I look forward to, you know, spending time with you and finding out what it is you do here. What do you do here? And Creed's little computer shuts down.
是的。霍莉是我们的外星人吗？是的。她只是这个星球上一个很棒的女人。天哪。好吧，霍莉会继续四处走动。她会继续认识办公室里的人。但在那之前，我们要不要休息一下？好的，因为我给克里德发了短信，关于克里德见到霍莉的那一刻。回来后我会分享。耶，我喜欢。好了，我们回来了。克里德和霍莉之间有一场精彩的戏，霍莉说，嘿，我期待着，你知道，和你共度时光，了解你在这里做什么。你在这里做什么？克里德的小电脑关机了。
His brain is like, oh God, oh, God. So I texted with Creed Bratton about this, and he said he was so excited for the scene. He knew it was definitely in his comedy wheelhouse. And he said he purposely took an extra long. beat after he shook hands with Holly and then walked away. He really wanted to drag out that moment. I thought it was so great because then it cuts to him hiding behind the refrigerator in the kitchen. And he's like, what is wrong with this woman? She's asking about stuff that's nobody's business. What do I do here? Qua, quack, quarr, quibbity, quare, quibbity, choir assurance.
他的大脑就像，哦天哪，哦天哪。所以我给克里德·布拉顿发了短信，他说他非常期待这场戏。他知道这绝对在他的喜剧范围内。他说他故意在和霍莉握手后又走开时，多停顿了很长一段时间。他真的想拖延那一刻。我觉得这太棒了，因为随后镜头切到他躲在厨房的冰箱后面。他说，这个女人怎么了？她问一些不关别人的事。我在这里做什么？质量，质量，质量，质量，质量保证。
Yes. His job is quality assurance. Yeah. And he's like, no, no, no, no, but I'm getting close. But I just thought Creed was so great and it. So good. Well, Dwight is going to ask Holly if she has met Kevin yet. And as part of his hazing, he is going to tell her that Kevin is here as part of a special work program because he is slow. She goes up to Kevin and she really goes out of her way. And he offers her some M&Ms. And Kevin is delighted that anyone is taking an interest in him. Right? Because all in Angela ever does is say, shut up, Kevin. I don't think Oscar talks to Kevin much.
是的。他的工作是质量保证。是的。他说，不，不，不，不，但我快想到了。但我只是觉得克里德太棒了。太好了。好吧，德怀特要问霍莉是否见过凯文了。作为他欺凌的一部分，他要告诉她凯文在这里是因为一个特殊的项目，因为他反应迟钝。她走到凯文身边，真的非常努力地对他好。他给了她一些M&M巧克力豆。凯文很高兴有人对他感兴趣。对吧？因为安吉拉只会说，闭嘴，凯文。我觉得奥斯卡没怎么和凯文说话。
He's stuck back there in that corner. He can't believe it. Someone cares about his M&Ms. I thought the way Amy Ryan as Holly did all of her scenes was brilliant. Well, Michael is going to come over, and he starts flirting with Holly. They are the worst. He says, if we hung you up, we'd have to kiss under you. He means mistletoe.
他被困在那个角落里。他简直不敢相信。有人关心他的M&M巧克力豆。我觉得艾米·瑞恩饰演的霍莉处理所有戏份的方式都很精彩。好吧，迈克尔要过来了，他开始和霍莉调情。他们真是太糟糕了。他说，如果我们把你挂起来，我们就得在你下面接吻。他指的是槲寄生。
And then he calls her a hologram. Then he says, and this sounds like something I would say, he says, are these guys boring your ears off? What would you say besides that? I think you say, are they talking, chatting your ear off? Not boring your ears off. That's not a saying. No one says that. Oh my gosh.
然后他叫她全息图。然后他说，这听起来像我会说的话，他说，这些家伙是在把你的耳朵说得无聊吗？除了那个你还会说什么？我想你会说，他们是在喋喋不休地烦你吗？不是把你的耳朵说得无聊。那不是一种说法。没人那么说。天哪。
I love that you are the person who is like, nobody says boring your ears off. When it's something you would totally say. I know. But Michael is flustered. And then, oh my gosh, you just starts speeding ahead. He's like, I'll make you a mix CD. What's your commute like? Oh, my gosh, Michael, slow down.
我喜欢你这种人，会说“没人会说把耳朵说得无聊”。当这完全是你自己会说的话时。我知道。但迈克尔慌了。然后，天哪，你只是开始加速了。他说，我会为你制作一张混音CD。你通勤怎么样？天哪，迈克尔，慢点。
Meanwhile, at reception, Pam gives Toby a going away present. It's a photo of everyone in the office. And he can take it with him to Costa Rica. Isn't that so nice? So nice. Jenna, I found this photo. I have it. You too?
与此同时，在前台，帕姆给了托比一份告别礼物。那是办公室所有人的合影。他可以带着它去哥斯达黎加。那不是很好吗？太好了。珍娜，我找到了这张照片。我有它。你也有？
Yeah, they gave it to all of us. But I'm not in it. You took it. Exactly. So yeah, I guess you didn't get it, but I have it. Oh my gosh. Everyone is facing forward, except for a small blonde accountant who's facing sideways tucked behind people. Why? I wonder why she's facing sideways. Oh my gosh. That is so funny. Yes, Jenna, they took this on set one day. We had to do that thing where we had to be in different wardrobe. You know what I mean? Yes. And we took this picture in between scenes one afternoon. That's amazing. Well, I'm not in it because I was taking.
是的，他们给了我们所有人。但我不在里面。你拍的。没错。所以是的，我想你没拿到，但我有。天哪。每个人都面向前方，除了一个小个子金发会计，她侧着身子躲在人后面。为什么？我想知道她为什么侧着身子。天哪。那太搞笑了。是的，珍娜，他们有一天在片场拍了这个。我们必须做那种必须穿不同服装的事情。你知道我的意思吗？是的。我们那天下午在两场戏之间拍了这张照片。太神奇了。好吧，我不在里面，因为我在拍。
it. Toby's very sad. And he's like, well, I love it. But maybe I could get a picture of just the two of us. And Pam's like, sure, do you have a camera? And then Toby like screams out. Does anyone have a camera? Paul was so good. I laughed so hard at that, Jenna. We had a fan question from Mariah A. when Toby yells, does anyone have a camera? Was that scripted? Angela, can you check the script? Yes. Okay.
它。托比非常难过。他说，好吧，我很喜欢它。但也许我可以拍一张我们俩的照片。帕姆说，当然，你有相机吗？然后托比大喊。有人有相机吗？保罗演得太好了。我笑得太厉害了，珍娜。我们有一个来自玛丽亚·A的粉丝问题，当托比大喊“有人有相机吗？”时，那是剧本写的吗？安吉拉，你能查一下剧本吗？是的。好的。
So it is in the script. It's written slightly different in the script. It says that Pam says, do you have your camera here? And Toby, louder than he's ever been, yells, who has a camera? Nobody answers. And Toby says, I'll go get one. So it is very similar. And it was in the script.
所以它在剧本里。剧本里写得稍微有点不同。它说帕姆说，你带相机了吗？然后托比，比他以往任何时候都大声地喊道，谁有相机？没人回答。托比说，我去拿一个。所以它非常相似。而且它确实在剧本里。
Oh, my gosh. It was so funny. I was thinking, at this point in the story, remember Ryan gave us all blackberries? There's a camera on your blackberry. I guess that won't do for Toby. He wants a proper photo. I think he wants a real deal picture. Well, next up, Jim's talking to Ryan on the phone.
天哪。太搞笑了。我在想，在故事的这一点上，记得瑞安给了我们所有人黑莓手机吗？你的黑莓手机上有摄像头。我想那对托比来说不行。他想要一张正经的照片。我想他想要一张真正的照片。好吧，接下来，吉姆在电话里和瑞安说话。
He's kind of bragging that he made a big sale. Ryan is not impressed. He's like, oh, congratulations, you did your job. Not only that. He says to Jim, don't interrupt. I mean, the Ryan sass. is strong. Mm-hmm.
他有点在吹嘘他做了一笔大生意。瑞安并不买账。他说，哦，恭喜你，你完成了你的工作。不仅如此。他对吉姆说，别打断我。我的意思是，瑞安的讽刺。很强烈。嗯哼。
Yeah. He tells Jim, did you log it in the website yet? Log it in the website. Jim's like, well, I already entered it as a sale. He's like, I don't care. Log it in the website. Ooh. Mm-hmm.
是的。他告诉吉姆，你在网站上记录了吗？在网站上记录。吉姆说，好吧，我已经把它作为销售额输入了。他说，我不在乎。在网站上记录。噢。嗯哼。
Ryan Sass. Can we now talk about my favorite scene of this episode? Which one is it? Michael in his office downloading the N3P music for his CD mixtape for Holly. That whole couplet wasn't in the script. What? Yeah, the N3P and the CD mixtape, that wasn't in the script. But the rest of the scene was, but just that language, which I have to think was either
瑞安的讽刺。我们现在能谈谈我这一集最喜欢的戏吗？是哪一场？迈克尔在他的办公室里下载N3P音乐，为霍莉制作CD混音带。那整段对白都不在剧本里。什么？是的，N3P和CD混音带，那不在剧本里。但剩下的戏都在，但只是那种语言，我不得不认为要么是
an alt or an ad lib, I don't know. Oh, I love it so much. And I love Jim's response, where he's like, close, not quite. Yep, no. Michael is asking Jim's advice. He needs to know what songs he should pick. that work on two levels. And here are the two levels.
一个替代方案或即兴发挥，我不知道。哦，我太喜欢了。我喜欢吉姆的反应，他说，接近了，但不完全是。是的，没有。迈克尔在征求吉姆的建议。他需要知道他应该选什么歌。在两个层面上起作用。这是两个层面。
Welcome to Scranton. And I love you. Yeah. And he fell in love with her when he first heard her voice. It was love at first C with my ears. Jim is going to try to get Michael to pump the brakes. Okay? And he says,
欢迎来到斯克兰顿。我爱你。是的。他在第一次听到她的声音时就爱上了她。这是我耳朵的“一见钟情”。吉姆要试着让迈克尔踩刹车。好吗？他说，
you know, I maybe have a little bit of experience with office romance. And Michael is like, who? Pam, that's still going on? I love this running joke that Michael is still surprised that they're dating. I know. It's so good. Well, he really tries to explain to Michael.
你知道，我可能有一点办公室恋爱的经验。迈克尔说，谁？帕姆，那还在继续吗？我喜欢这个反复出现的笑话，迈克尔仍然对他们在约会感到惊讶。我知道。太好了。好吧，他真的试图向迈克尔解释。
You can have this romance, but you just have to take it slow. Let it build. Basically, he's saying, don't be a weirdo, Michael. Don't be Michael, Michael. Yeah. Take a new approach on this one. But this whole conversation where Jim is talking about his romance with Pam, All of these milestone moments in their relationship took place at work in the office,
你可以有这段恋情，但你只需要慢慢来。让它建立起来。基本上，他在说，别做一个怪人，迈克尔。别做迈克尔，迈克尔。是的。这次换个方法。但吉姆谈论他与帕姆的恋情的这段对话，他们关系中所有这些里程碑式的时刻都发生在办公室的工作中，
leads him to realize he should propose to her at work. Tonight, at the party. Full Circle Life moment. It should happen at Dunder Mifflin. It's really sweet. Jim goes into the conference room. He says, Phyllis, I want fireworks at this party. And then he hands her an envelope of cash.
让他意识到他应该在工作中向她求婚。今晚，在派对上。生命轮回的时刻。它应该发生在邓德·米夫林。真的很甜。吉姆走进会议室。他说，菲利斯，我想要这个派对上有烟花。然后他递给她一个装满现金的信封。
Yes. Lady, there is a deleted scene. where when Jim walks in, he's like, hey, Phyllis, how's it going? And Phyllis goes, Jim, I'm f***. And they bleeped it out, but she clearly throws down the F bomb. And Jim's like, okay. It's so great. There's so many good Phyllis deleted scenes.
是的。女士，有一个删减片段。当吉姆走进去时，他说，嘿，菲利斯，怎么样？菲利斯说，吉姆，我搞砸了。他们消音了，但她显然说了F开头的脏话。吉姆说，好吧。太棒了。有太多好的菲利斯删减片段了。
Oh, my gosh. Yeah, but she's excited to get fireworks. She needs some showstopper moments, so this is good. Should we go into the break room? Kevin is staring at the vending machine. He's trying to decide what to get when Holly sees him. She's going to come help him. They could not get through this scene, by the way.
天哪。是的，但她很兴奋能得到烟花。她需要一些压轴时刻，所以这很好。我们要去休息室吗？凯文正盯着自动售货机。他正试图决定买什么，这时霍莉看到了他。她要来帮他。顺便说一句，他们无法完成这场戏。
They could not. There's bloopers from this scene. Oh, fan catch from Abby M. She thinks Brian's about to laugh on the button line. I mean, he almost breaks. He did repeatedly when they filmed it. So there's no doubt to me that she caught him breaking. This scene does it for Kevin.
他们不能。这场戏有花絮。哦，来自艾比·M的粉丝发现。她认为布莱恩在最后一句台词时快要笑了。我的意思是，他差点破功。他们拍摄时他反复破功。所以我毫不怀疑她抓住了他破功的瞬间。这场戏对凯文来说很关键。
He's like, I'm going to bang Holly. She is cute and helpful and seems really into me. Yeah. Kevin has found his person. He has. Lady, at 16 minutes, 18 seconds, I have titled this, wauza. Go Jim. Oh, yeah.
他心想，我要和霍莉上床。她可爱又乐于助人，看起来真的很喜欢我。是的。凯文找到了他的知音。他找到了。女士，在16分18秒，我给它起名叫，哇。加油吉姆。哦，是的。
Jim is Hot to Trot. And he calls Ryan. Wait, lady, hot to trot means up for sex. Hot to Trot. I thought it means you're all fired up. You're fired up to hook up. Are you sure? Hot to trot is like you get all dressed up to go out to a bar.
吉姆“跃跃欲试”。他给瑞安打电话。等等，女士，“跃跃欲试”意味着准备好做爱。跃跃欲试。我以为它意味着你很兴奋。你很兴奋去勾搭。你确定吗？跃跃欲试就像你盛装打扮去酒吧。
I'm hot to trot. Anyone? Sam, Cassie. I have been saying this like when someone's irritated my whole life. I've always used it that way too, Jenna. Thank you. Hot to trot. It's like you're fired up to, you know, meet someone and hook up and get it on.
我跃跃欲试。有人吗？萨姆，卡西。我一生中当有人被激怒时一直这么说。我一直也是那样用的，珍娜。谢谢。跃跃欲试。就像你很兴奋去，你知道，见某人并勾搭并开始。
I thought it just meant you were pissed on. No, it doesn't. Angela, I have to ask in what scenarios have you been using it then? I mean, Sam, I'm like racking my brain now of how many times I said this wrong and someone probably thought, what is up with this lady? Where I'm like, oh yeah, I was at the grocery store. I was hot to trot. They didn't have any of the items I went there.
我以为它只是意味着你被激怒了。不，不是。安吉拉，我得问问你是在什么情况下使用它的？我的意思是，萨姆，我现在绞尽脑汁想我说了多少次错话，有人可能想，这个女人怎么了？我心想，哦是的，我在杂货店。我跃跃欲试。他们没有我想要的任何东西。
They're like, wow, Angela gets really turned on at the grocery store when they don't have the items she needs. She gets hot to trot. Oh, yeah, I went to kick gas and I was going to use the car wash, but it didn't work and I'd already paid the machine, I was hot to trot. Oh, no. Oh, I've been doing it wrong, guys. Well, learn something every day.
他们心想，哇，安吉拉在杂货店没有她需要的商品时真的很兴奋。她跃跃欲试。哦，是的，我去加油，我打算洗车，但它没用，我已经付了钱，我跃跃欲试。哦，不。哦，我一直用错了，伙计们。好吧，每天学点新东西。
Okay. You could say Jim is coming in hot on the call to Ryan. Fired up? I think you're looking for fired up. I think I'm looking for hot and bothered. Yeah, hot and bothered is also a little bit sexy. Oh, my gosh. Oh, I'm so hot and bothered right now.
好的。你可以说吉姆在给瑞安打电话时很火大。兴奋？我想你在找“兴奋”。我想我在找“心烦意乱”。是的，“心烦意乱”也有一点点性感。天哪。哦，我现在太心烦意乱了。
You're looking for fired up. up. You're thinking fire. That's making you think hot. You want to take hot out of it. Taking hot out. fired up. He is fired up. He is fired up. He's ready to trot. He calls Ryan and he leaves this message. And he's like, hey, Ryan, it's Jim. Look, man, I don't know what's gotten into you lately. But you know what? I really don't care because you're trying to get rid of me. And I bet you don't think I care enough about this job to actually fight back. But you're wrong because I do and I will. So you can keep trying to push me out of this place. But guess what? I'm not going anywhere. hangs up the phone because he is hot, he's fired up, he's bothered, he's pissed.
你在找“兴奋”。你在想火。这让你想到了热。你想把“热”去掉。去掉热。兴奋。他很兴奋。他很兴奋。他准备好出发了。他给瑞安打电话，留下了这条信息。他说，嘿，瑞安，我是吉姆。听着，伙计，我不知道你最近怎么了。但你知道吗？我真的不在乎，因为你想摆脱我。我敢打赌你认为我不在乎这份工作，不会真的反击。但你错了，因为我在乎，我会的。所以你可以继续试图把我赶出这里。但猜猜怎么着？我哪儿也不去。挂断电话，因为他很火大，他很兴奋，他很心烦，他很生气。
You know what, Angela? Pam isn't there to hear this phone call, but if she had heard it, she would have been hot to trot. Somebody in this scenario is hot to trot. It's Pam. Well, now Michael is going to go back to HR. He can't find Holly. Where is she? You know where she is? She's on the floor. She's taken apart her chair. In the script, it says Holly is sitting. acutely on the floor. She explains to Michael that she's trying to fix the lumbar support on her chair, and she's like,
你知道吗，安吉拉？帕姆不在那里听到这个电话，但如果她听到了，她会跃跃欲试的。这个场景里的某个人跃跃欲试。是帕姆。好吧，现在迈克尔要回到人力资源部。他找不到霍莉。她在哪里？你知道她在哪里吗？她在地板上。她拆开了她的椅子。剧本里说霍莉正坐在地板上。她向迈克尔解释说她正试图修理椅子的腰部支撑，她说，
great story, huh? I'm going to sell the movie rights. Michael is so excited. There's a bit. There's a bit. So he goes, and the sequel, woman stands at desk and works. And Holly laughs. She chuckles. She chuckles. So Michael's going to get down on the floor with her. He offers to help her put her chair back together. But he can't sit how she's sitting. He says, how are you sitting like that? And she's says yoga. Well, Michael's brain, here's yoga, and then he does a Yoda impression. Sit on floor and put chair together, we will. And then there's this pause. And you're like, oh, no, oh, no, she doesn't think he's funny. Oh, no. But then she does a Yoda impression back. Oh,
很棒的故事，对吧？我要卖掉电影版权。迈克尔太兴奋了。有一个梗。有一个梗。所以他说，续集，女人站在桌边工作。霍莉笑了。她轻笑。她轻笑。所以迈克尔要和她一起坐在地板上。他主动提出帮她把椅子装回去。但他不能像她那样坐。他说，你怎么能那样坐？她说瑜伽。好吧，迈克尔的大脑听到了瑜伽，然后他模仿了尤达。坐在地板上把椅子装好，我们会。然后有一段停顿。你心想，哦不，哦不，她觉得他不好笑。哦不。但随后她也模仿了尤达。哦，
melt my heart. Past curvy metal piece, you will. That's it. Michael is sunk. He is so in love. You know, Amy Ryan did not know Yoda? What? Mm-hmm. She had to Google scenes of Yoda in order to get the voice right. Well, she nailed it. She nailed it. Good job, Amy. Clearly you're in the Jenna Club of not knowing Star Wars. I'm going to let it slide.
融化了我的心。把弯曲的金属片递过来，你会的。就是这样。迈克尔沦陷了。他太爱了。你知道，艾米·瑞恩不知道尤达？什么？嗯哼。她不得不谷歌尤达的片段来让声音正确。好吧，她做到了。她做到了。干得好，艾米。显然你加入了珍娜的“不知道星球大战”俱乐部。我会让它过去。
Well, Michael, he is so smitten, right? But he's trying to take Jim's advice. So he very awkwardly asks Holly if she's going to be in town this weekend. but then says, because I won't be. Yeah. Hey, you're going to be in town this weekend? Because I won't be. What? I know.
好吧，迈克尔，他太迷恋了，对吧？但他试图听从吉姆的建议。所以他非常尴尬地问霍莉这个周末是否在城里。但随后说，因为我不在。是的。嘿，你这个周末在城里吗？因为我不在。什么？我知道。
And she says, that's too bad. You're going to miss my orgy. And Michael is like, what? I mean, in addition to the Yoda impression, now she makes a kind of sexy joke, which is usually Michael's wheelhouse, right? Yeah. And then she's like kidding.
她说，那太糟糕了。你会错过我的狂欢派对。迈克尔说，什么？我的意思是，除了尤达模仿，现在她开了一个有点性感的玩笑，这通常是迈克尔的领域，对吧？是的。然后她说开玩笑。
And then he's like, kidding. Acting. And she knows immediately acting. They're doing love it. Both of them. Yeah. John Lovitz played this character on S&L called The Master Thespian.
然后他说，开玩笑。演戏。她立刻知道是演戏。他们正在享受。他们两个。是的。约翰·洛维茨在SNL上扮演过这个角色，叫“大师演员”。
And it's such a funny bit. He's like this sort of ego-maniacal actor. And he spoke with like this sort of plummy Shakespearean accent. And he would try to trick the other people in the scenes into believing he was hurt or that like something terrible was happening. And then when they would stop the see, be like, oh, are you okay? He'd be like, ha-ha, acting. It was such a funny bit.
这是一个非常有趣的梗。他就像那种自负的演员。他用那种李子般的莎士比亚口音说话。他会试图欺骗戏里的其他人，让他们相信他受伤了或者发生了什么可怕的事情。然后当他们停止戏份时，会说，哦，你还好吗？他会说，哈哈，演戏。这是一个非常有趣的梗。
So that's what they're bonding over now. It's just amazing. This scene was so charming, right? It was so cute. Amazing. Well, building on this moment, there was another scene in the shooting draft where Holly and Michael are in the kitchen at the same time and they're sharing coffee and they're doing cookie monster impressions.
所以这就是他们现在建立联系的原因。太神奇了。这场戏太迷人了，对吧？太可爱了。太棒了。好吧，基于这一刻，拍摄草稿中还有另一场戏，霍莉和迈克尔同时在厨房里，他们分享咖啡，他们在模仿饼干怪兽。
Oh, my God. I know. And I'm sure when they edited it, they were like, we don't have enough time for both. Let's pick one. So they did the Yoda scene. But they sort of spent the whole day doing these bits together. It's really sweet. Well, it makes sense then when Michael rushes over to Jim's desk.
天哪。我知道。我相信当他们剪辑时，他们会说，我们没有足够的时间做两个。选一个吧。所以他们做了尤达那场戏。但他们基本上花了一整天时间一起做这些梗。真的很甜。好吧，那迈克尔冲向吉姆的办公桌时就说得通了。
And everyone, as you watch this scene, I just want you to remember that Steve Correll never won an Emmy Award for playing Michael Scott on the office. And it is a tragedy because this scene. This scene of him, he is so wired. He says, I, I laid a base. I laid a base. And even though I wanted to kiss her, I didn't. I mean, it's such good acting. It's so good.
大家，当你们看这场戏时，我只是想让你们记住，史蒂夫·卡瑞尔从未因在《办公室》中扮演迈克尔·斯科特而获得艾美奖。这是一个悲剧，因为这场戏。这场戏，他太紧张了。他说，我，我打下了基础。我打下了基础。即使我想吻她，我也没有。我的意思是，这是非常好的表演。太棒了。
All of it. I know. Well, Phyllis now is going to go over to Angela and admit that she needs some help with the party planning. She's going to need the vendors that Angela has. All the lists, all the phone numbers, right? You know what? You know what just happened to that vendor list? Oh, someone shredded it.
所有的一切。我知道。好吧，菲利斯现在要去找安吉拉，承认她需要一些派对策划方面的帮助。她需要安吉拉拥有的供应商。所有的名单，所有的电话号码，对吧？你知道吗？你知道那个供应商名单刚刚发生了什么吗？哦，有人把它粉碎了。
just now. And Phyllis is like, why would you do that? And Angela says, hmm, why do you think? Yeah, I just don't know. So good, Angela. You're so good in that scene. And then Phyllis knocks the papers off of Angela's desk. I have two things to share. First of all, that whole scene was in the script. And Phyllis knocking the papers off the desk. I wanted to see if that was in the script, it was. So that was all written out. But I wanted to share something with you guys. I remember when we rehearsed the scene, because you know, you guys, we would rehearse for camera so they would know where to line up their shots, right? When Phyllis said to me in the rehearsal, can I get a list of your vendors? I'm supposed to bend over quickly, hold the basket up and say, I shredded it. There was no
就在刚才。菲利斯说，你为什么要那样做？安吉拉说，嗯，你觉得呢？是的，我不知道。太好了，安吉拉。你在那场戏里演得太好了。然后菲利斯把安吉拉桌上的文件扫到了地上。我有两件事要分享。首先，整场戏都在剧本里。菲利斯把文件扫到地上。我想看看那是否在剧本里，确实在。所以那都是写好的。但我有个事想和你们分享。我记得我们排练那场戏的时候，因为你知道，伙计们，我们会为摄像机排练，这样他们就知道在哪里排队拍摄，对吧？当菲利斯在排练中对我说，我能拿到你的供应商名单吗？我应该快速弯腰，举起篮子说，我把它粉碎了。根本没有
quickly about it. I was very pregnant. I couldn't reach the basket. They said on the ground easily. So I was like, And then they're like, okay, that's not going to do. We can't see you struggling to reach the garbage bin, right? Yes. So Matt Sone, who was so sweet, who was our camera operator, he was like, let's just set it on an Apple box. You won't see it. So Angela doesn't have to bend all the way down to the floor.
快速可言。我怀孕很明显。我够不到篮子。他们说在地上很容易。所以我心想，然后他们说，好吧，那不行。我们不能看着你挣扎着去够垃圾桶，对吧？是的。所以马特·索恩，他太贴心了，他是我们的摄像师，他说，把它放在苹果箱上吧。你看不见的。所以安吉拉不必一直弯腰到地板上。
So if you watch the scene, I have that basket so ready to go. It's because I don't even have to bend over to reach it. It's right there. Yes, I was very pregnant, guys. This is something that comes up for Genesis. and I, as we rewatch these episodes, there's real life that meets the fiction, right? All of the memories of what you had to go through to make these scenes work. To pick up a trash bin when you're super pregnant.
所以如果你看这场戏，我把那个篮子准备得很好。那是因为我甚至不需要弯腰去够它。它就在那里。是的，我怀孕很明显，伙计们。这是珍娜和我重温这些剧集时会出现的事情，现实生活与虚构相遇，对吧？所有为了让这些戏成功而必须经历的记忆。当你怀孕时去捡垃圾桶。
Exactly. Well, now we cut back to Michael and Holly, kind of still working on the chair and Toby approaches, and Michael needs to get rid of Toby. He's like, why don't you go home and come back for the party? But Toby says, while we still have to do my exit interview, bum bum. All right, guys, Michael has a talking head. He says he's been steeped in anticipation of this moment.
没错。好吧，现在我们切回迈克尔和霍莉，还在修理椅子，托比走近了，迈克尔需要摆脱托比。他说，你为什么不回家，派对时再回来？但托比说，我们还得做我的离职面谈，砰砰。好了，伙计们，迈克尔有一个采访片段。他说他一直沉浸在对这一刻的期待中。
Toby has been, quote, cruising for a bruising for 12 years. And my name is Captain Bruzen. The look on Michael's face says it all. He has been waiting for this moment for a long time. And he can't wait. I'm sorry to tell you. that we're going to stop here. You will have to wait for this exit interview.
托比，引用的话，12年来一直在自讨苦吃。我的名字是布鲁森队长。迈克尔脸上的表情说明了一切。他等待这一刻已经很久了。他等不及了。很抱歉告诉你们。我们要在这里停下来。你们必须等待这次离职面谈。
It's how we will start out next week with Goodbye Toby Part 2. It's so good. I loved this episode. Thank you so much to Jen Salata, Paul Lieberstein, Kitz Saboranak, Creed Bratton, for letting us hit you up with questions about this episode. I love our office family so much. They show up for us every week, you guys. Big love to those folks.
这就是我们下周开始的方式，再见托比第二部分。太棒了。我喜欢这一集。非常感谢珍·萨拉塔、保罗·利伯斯坦、基茨·萨博拉纳克、克里德·布拉顿，让我们向你们询问关于这一集的问题。我太爱我们的办公室大家庭了。伙计们，他们每周都为我们出现。给那些人满满的爱。
They are really helping us get all the details of these episodes. And I love that we're recording it. We're going to have it. We're going to have this record. Forever. Forever. All right. Goodbye, Toby.
他们真的在帮助我们获取这些剧集的所有细节。我喜欢我们正在录制它。我们会拥有的。我们会拥有这个记录。永远。永远。好了。再见，托比。
Part one is done. You know you're hot to trot for next week and we'll be here. We sure will be. We'll see you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
第一部分完成了。你知道你下周跃跃欲试，我们会在这里的。我们当然会。到时候见。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。